So in the last problem of this homework assignment,
we’re going to take a look at the complexity of
parsing certain strings of input under certain
grammars. Is it the case that certain grammars are
more difficult to parse with the algorithms that we’ve
given? Is it case that certain strings are more difficult
to parse with the same algorithms? And just in case it
wasn’t clear, this is definitely a challenge problem
and very, very difficult. So please don’t be upset.
If you want to able to get a good solution, if you dig
your working solution I hope you shattered on the
forms with your fellow students and discuss how you
got there. So to recap, we’re trying to answer the
question, how much work is it the parse? And before
we answer that, we need to decide in someway to
measure this work. We could take the time that it
takes to run the parsing, maybe measure in seconds or
minutes. We could take the energy when you have a
web browser and something like my phone, then we
need to decide whether or not our web browser is
efficient enough not to drain my phone four hours
into the day. I’m sure that happen to some of you
before. So this might be measured in lots or some of
the measurement of power.
There is something wrong with each of these forms of
measurements. And that is it doesn’t really get at the
algorithm. If I buy a faster computer, does that mean
my parser is better? No. if you build a more energy
efficient phone, does that mean the parser is better?
Not really. So measuring in such units would imply
that our algorithms get better over time as the
hardware does. But the truth is many algorithms
haven’t gone better since when they were first
developed and say the 70s. So we want a union of
measurements that is independent on the hardware
we’re running on. That way if I test my parser, I can
compare it to your parser even though it’s very
unlikely we’re running the exact same computer.
Instead we’re going to find our own unit of
measurement.
For now let’s call it a work operation. We’re going to
count the number of work operations it takes to parse,
a given list of, a given string and our grammar. For
this problem you were asked to give two things, a
grammar and a list of tokens that takes at least two X,
X, X work operations to parse where X is going to be
defined as the maximum number of input tokens or
the size of the largest grammar rule or the number of
rules.
So why is this definition special? It means that we
can’t just give a really long list of tokens and expect
to reach two times what is essentially x3 work
operations. We have to find something that given the
relative size of the grammar to tokens and the rules is
more work to parse. The key to solving this problem
is actually ambiguity. It turns out ambiguity really
slows down the parsing process, given the set of
rules that we’ve defined for parsing a given list of
tokens.
So let’s look at a really ambiguous grammar.
This grammar matches a sequence of Xs, but
because of this rule right here it’s very, very
ambiguous.
As it turns out that if you have the or more Xs in a
row to actually break the two times x3 mark for
parsing.
But for the sake of demonstrating this,
I’m going to just show you what the parse chart looks
like with five Xs.
So here I’ve taken the code given in the problem
uncommented dissection that prints the chart and
I’ve run the grammar that we had on a string
of five tokens.
The results, is as follows. Right from the get
go there is a lot different rules that we can match.
And with every step we keep getting more and more
possibilities due to all the ambiguity. Everywhere that
we could possibly have a P or putting in two more Ps
and then from there even two more Ps. As it turns
out for N characters we get about n2 possible
Pastries.
And that means the size of our chart alone includes a
lot more than the possible Pastries and we do a lot
more work operations as we try to go through that.
So by the end, we’ve done 3,237 units of work. Now
if we increase the number of tokens to something like
50, we get a very long parse chart. And that will just
keep scrolling and so hit the bottom. Get some
longer and longer and longer, and oh my gosh,
does it end.
Here we go. Yeah, it gets pretty big. One thing to
note that I didn’t do in my examples was that
the length of your input needed to be greater than 10
and less than 50.
And by inputting mean the number X. So here I
had Xs 50 and before I had a 5, but that’s why I
neither of these were accepted. So if you did
something say, 11 you will get a success that
encourages you to copy and submit it. I hope you
had fun doing this problem and it’s a bit more
creative than what we’ve had in the past.
And there is many, many right answers.
I hope to see some of those answers on the form.
Until then bye, bye. I will end with this manifest.